.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Menschen haben Ziele.
Beim Triathlon zählen für die meisten
nur Zeit und Rang.
Menschen haben Narben,
doch oft sieht man sie nicht.
Philipp hat so viele Narben,
dass er die Blicke auf sich zieht.
Das ist ihm unangenehm
und kostet Kraft.
Nur schon am Start zu stehen, fühlt
sich für ihn darum an wie ein Sieg.
Mental habe ich mein Ziel
hier schon erreicht.
Aber ich möchte natürlich
den Triathlon auch abschliessen.
Ein Triathlet, der nicht nur
möglichst schnell ankommen will.
Ein Triathlet, dessen grösster Gegner
die Blicke der anderen sind.
Doch an diesem Septembermorgen
in Locarno
hat Philipp
seine Angst einmal mehr besiegt.
* Düstere Klänge *
Es passierte im Kanton Aargau,
am 2. Juni 2014.
Wir machten Bohrungen
für eine Hangsicherung.
Der Bohrkopf des Bohrgerätes
brach auf gut 10 m Tiefe ab,
weil er auf Fels gestossen war.
Es ging darum,
eine Vorrichtung anzuschweissen,
damit wir danach
einen Haken einhängen konnten,
um den Bohrkopf mit Ketten
bergen zu können.
Ich schweisste dann
mit einer Elektrode.
Immer, wenn ich schweisste,
also wenn der Funken kam,
nahm mir das Sauerstoff weg.
Ich hatte keinen Platz in der Röhre.
Ich hatte eine Taschenlampe im Mund,
um überhaupt etwas zu sehen.
Es wurde dann Sauerstoff zugeführt,
weil der Sauerstoffmangel
in dieser Tiefe noch grösser wurde,
wenn ich punktete.
Das sammelte sich an und ...
... führte dann
zum Inferno in der Röhre drin.
Es dauerte ein bisschen mehr
als 10 bis 15 Sek.,
bis ich aus dem Feuer gezogen wurde.
Aber das war fast ...
... der harmlosere Teil.
Im Feuer drin zu sein.
Danach ...
Die Haut
und die Gedanken an das Feuer ...
Ich hatte ja gesehen, wie sich
mein Hemd und meine Hose auflösten.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich noch Kleider anhatte.
Was meine Vorstellung
danach auslöste ...
Also, wie der Körper aussieht,
wenn die Kleider weg sind ...
Das war für mich die reine Hölle.
Philipp
wird ins Unispital Zürich geflogen,
in die Intensivstation
für Brandverletzte.
Er wird ins künstliche Koma versetzt.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man
einen so schweren Unfall überlebt,
lag zwischen 5 und maximal 10 %.
Russ, Schmutz und Blasen werden
in der Eintrittswanne entfernt.
Alle Haare werden
wegen der Infektionsgefahr rasiert.
Die Haut ist so weiss,
weil sie nicht mehr durchblutet wird.
Die tote Haut
muss weggeschnitten werden.
Das
ist ein beschädigter Schutzmantel.
Das ist der letzte Moment,
in dem er diesen Schutzmantel hat.
Den entfernt man dann.
88 % von Philipps Haut
sind verbrannt.
In den ersten 30 Tagen
wird er 20-mal operiert.
Die Wunden sollen
so schnell wie möglich vernarben
und den Körper vor Keimen schützen.
Man versucht, kleinste Hautinseln
auf die Wunden zu transplantieren,
an denen die Haut entfernt wurde.
Bei jemandem,
der so schwer verbrannt ist,
hat man sehr wenig eigene Haut
zur Verfügung.
Man macht dann
mit vielen kleinen Punkten,
wie Sie das hier auf dem Bild sehen,
ein Schachbrettmuster,
um die verfügbare Haut auszudehnen.
Das wird dann mit sog. Spenderhaut
übertransplantiert.
Sie sehen,
wie diese kleinen, braunen Inselchen
sich eigentlich durch
diese Spenderhaut durcharbeiten
und ausbreiten.
Die Spenderhaut
funktioniert wie ein Gerüst,
an dem sich die eigenen Hautzellen
entwickeln können.
Das endet dann
in einer vollständigen Wundheilung.
Da haben Sie mit sehr wenig Haut
eine grosse Fläche erzeugt.
Es gibt Tage, die weniger gut sind
und an denen
einem wirklich die Kraft fehlt.
Aber was ihn auszeichnet, ist,
dass er alle Möglichkeiten,
die wir ihm geboten haben,
angenommen, für sich damit etwas
gemacht und seinen Weg gesucht hat.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ich wollte schon immer mal
in die Altstadt Bülach ziehen.
Diese Altbauten und der alte Kern
gefallen mir sehr.
Ich bin auch so aufgewachsen,
in einem alten Bauernhaus.
Ich habe hier
ein bisschen Anonymität.
Die Leute lernen mich so kennen,
wie ich bin.
Die Vergangenheit ...
... wie man aufgewachsen ist vor
dem Unfall, ist weniger ein Thema.
Wenn ich mich
nicht so viel bewegen würde -
sei das tagsüber oder anhand dieser
Übungen und der Physiotherapie ...
Das schlimmste Szenario ist,
dass ich meine Selbstständigkeit
verlieren könnte.
Dass ich meinen Alltag
nicht mehr selber bewältigen kann.
Das alles
beginnt beim Bewegungsapparat.
Ein einfaches Beispiel:
Schuhe binden.
Halt viel Feinmotorisches:
kochen oder Kleider anziehen.
In der Nacht zieht es mich
in eine Fötusstellung.
Der Narbenzug
ist vorne am stärksten.
Ich erwache dann
in dieser Fötusstellung.
Morgens ist es so ...
... als würde ich
in einem Kleidungsstück
der Grösse XS stecken.
Ich sollte aber Grösse L haben.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich wollte in erster Linie,
dass sich mein Alltag verbessert.
Durch den Ausdauersport merkte ich,
dass ich auch im Alltag
stärker belastbar werde.
Ich hatte mehr Energie.
Und es half mir auch ...
... mental und seelisch sehr stark.
Ja, seither wurde der Sport
zu meiner Therapie.
Schwimmtraining - ausnahmsweise an
einem verregneten Samstagnachmittag.
Sonst
geht Philipp am Morgen schwimmen,
um anderen Menschen
aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Nach der Autobahnausfahrt
sieht man direkt auf den Parkplatz.
So sehe ich sofort,
wie viele Autos dastehen.
Da wird es mir jeweils ...
... schon fast übel.
Am liebsten würde ich
vor der Schranke umkehren.
Aber ich muss das Schwimmtraining
machen und möchte mich verbessern.
V.a. möchte ich mich auch
dieser Konfrontation stellen.
Das trifft mich schon.
Wenn ich andere Leute
im Hallenbad grüsse,
merke ich, wie stark sie
mein Anblick irritiert.
Ich möchte das nicht auslösen.
Das trifft mich jeweils.
Man merkt, dass die Leute aus-
weichen, weil sie überfordert sind.
Sie richten den Blick dann lieber
auf den Boden und sagen nichts
oder nehmen Abstand.
Da sieht man auf den Parkplatz.
Er ist pumpenvoll.
Wenn ich sonst schwimmen gehe,
ist normalerweise
nicht mal die Hälfte voll.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Es ist wie immer:
Philipp zieht die Blicke auf sich.
Dieser Herausforderung stellt
er sich zwei- bis dreimal pro Woche.
Philipp will nur eines:
so schnell wie möglich ins Becken
und die Blicke abschütteln.
Das Schwimmen
ist mehr als Therapie und Training.
Es ist auch gut fürs Gemüt.
Beim Schwimmen
spüre ich eine Freiheit.
Ich spüre das Leben dabei extrem.
Es ist halt ein monotoner Ablauf,
aber gerade wenn man in einen Flow
kommt und gleiten kann,
ist das wie fliegen.
Ich kann dabei sehr gut
über alles nachdenken.
Was löst Philipps Anblick
bei anderen aus?
Im ersten Moment Irritation.
Und dann viele Fragen.
Schämt er sich? Ist es ihm peinlich
oder unangenehm, wenn man glotzt?
Das könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Vielleicht kann ich ihn das fragen.
Oder sagt er:
"Das bin ich und ich stehe dazu."
"Du kannst normal mit mir sprechen.
Das ist nur meine Haut."
"Ich bin nicht ansteckend."
Ich denke, das muss man rausfühlen.
Man kann und sollte das fragen.
Ich finde es am angenehmsten,
wenn die Leute mich fragen.
Dann kann man ...
Dann hat man eine Chance zu sagen,
was los ist.
So hat man
nicht immer diese Distanz.
Die Leute sind oft irritiert
und es trifft mich,
wenn die Leute das machen.
Ja gut, aber bei dir ...
Ich habe das zuerst
gar nicht gesehen.
Ich schaute dir dabei zu,
wie du schwimmst.
Ich sehe mir gerne
die Schwimmstile an.- Ich auch.
Gibt es solche Begegnungen
unter Schwimmerkollegen häufig?
Eigentlich nicht. Sehr selten.
Die Leute halten eher Abstand
und trauen sich nicht
oder sind vielleicht überfordert.
Sie hörten kaum auf zu schwatzen.
Um was ging es?
Das ist sehr interessant.
Meine positive Art hat ihn
anscheinend stark fasziniert.
Er sah natürlich auch,
dass etwas passiert war.
Aber er hat die Stärke dahinter
gesehen und fand cool,
dass ich das mache
und die Konfrontation annehme.
Das ist für mich auch sehr schön.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
* Lockere Musik *
Freunde.
Gemeinsam aufgewachsen
im 2'000-Seelen-Dorf Hochfelden.
Gemeinsam
im Turn- oder im Schiessverein.
Sie treffen sich jeden Donnerstag.
Für mich ist Philipp ...
... eigentlich ein Mensch,
den man bewundern kann.
Für mich ist das ...
Was er erlebt und durchgemacht hat,
ist wahnsinnig.
Das kann man fast nicht beschreiben.
Man hat viele Tage im Geschäft,
an denen man sich fragt,
wie man das alles lösen soll
und man sorgt sich um alles.
Privat hat man auch noch Sorgen.
Da kommt mir oft Philipp
in den Sinn.
Das ist wahnsinnig.
Es ist verdammt schwierig,
das zu beschreiben.
Ich glaube,
er hat schon noch daran zu beissen.
Es gab Zeiten, in denen man ihn
ein paar Tage in Ruhe lassen musste.
Er sagte dann,
er bleibe an diesem Abend zu Hause.
Aber ich glaube,
das ist jetzt etwas abgeflaut.
Das gibt es ein bisschen weniger.
Seit er angefangen hat,
Extremsport zu machen ...
... hat er sich extrem verändert.
Zum Positiven. Das ist das Beste,
was ihm hätte passieren können.
Der Sport hat ihn etwas verändert,
das ist so.
Aber vom Äusserlichen her ...
Er ist immer noch
mein kleiner Bruder.
Er sieht für mich
noch wie vorher aus.
Für mich
hat er sich nicht verändert.
Nach dem Unfall
waren seine Freunde für Philipp da.
Ohne Familie und Freunde
hätte er wohl nicht überlebt,
sagen die Ärzte.
In der Zeit,
als ich auf der Intensivstation lag,
unternahmen sie
alles Menschenmögliche,
damit ich weiterhin
Kontakt zu ihnen haben konnte.
Wenn es möglich war,
besuchten sie mich auch oft.
Ich hatte immer Anschluss,
obwohl ich total isoliert war.
Freunde - einer nach dem anderen
heiratet, gründet eine Familie.
Auch für Philipp ist dieses Kapitel
nicht abgeschlossen.
Als der Unfall passierte,
war ich in einer Beziehung.
Die konnte dem nicht standhalten.
Aber nicht von ihrer Seite her,
sondern weil ich sie
sozusagen gehen lassen wollte.
Ich wusste nicht,
wie es weitergehen würde.
Ich habe mich stark gefragt,
ob ich je wieder
einen Partner finden werde.
Ich setzte mich dadurch
auch unter Druck.
Aber mittlerweile liegt das so weit
zurück und ist sekundär für mich.
Es ist nicht etwas,
das jetzt wichtig ist.
Wenn es kommt, ist das umso schöner.
Dann ist es
auch der richtige Zeitpunkt.
Momentan
bin ich wirklich noch etwas ...
Ich lerne mich selber
in dieser neuen Hülle noch kennen.
Besuch im Spital.
Philipp hat den Kontakt zu Pflegenden
und Ärzten stets aufrechterhalten.
Die Zeit auf der Intensivstation
für Brandverletzte
hat zusammengeschweisst.
Die Station, auf der er ein ganzes
Jahr verbrachte, ist heute verwaist.
Sie wurde in
einen moderneren Gebäudeteil verlegt.
Ein leeres Zimmer
voller Erinnerungen.
Als ich erwachte
bzw. aus dem Koma geholt wurde,
standen viele Ärzte hier.
Anfangs schauten mal alle
mit grossen Augen.
Ich wohl auch.
Die Augen waren das Einzige,
was man von mir sah.
Sonst war alles in Verbände
eingepackt, wie eine Mumie.
Ich lag hier.
Ich weiss noch ...
... dass ich fragte, ob ich
jemals wieder Sport machen könne.
Ich wollte wieder
Downhill-Velo fahren.
Da mussten die Ärzte auch lachen.
Also, das war natürlich
ein bisschen surreal.
Ich empfand
in dieser Situation nicht,
dass ich total eingeschränkt war.
An dem Baum habe ich v.a. ...
... die Jahreszeiten
an mir vorbeiziehen sehen.
Frühling, Sommer,
dann ging es in den Herbst rein ...
In dieser Zeit
kam mir das alles surreal vor.
Mein Zeitempfinden
fühlte sich gar nicht so lange an,
wie ich wirklich hier war.
Aber ich konnte
an den Blättern sehen,
wie die Jahreszeiten vorbeigingen.
Aber ich habe die Zeit
nicht so wahrgenommen.
Ich dachte nicht,
dass ich schon so lange hier liege.
Zwei Monate künstliches Koma,
dann ein halbes Jahr,
in dem Philipp
sich nicht bewegen konnte.
Wie es unter den Verbänden aussah,
wusste er nicht.
Die Verbände
wurden unter Vollnarkose gewechselt.
Obwohl der Kopf
auch immer verbunden war,
machte ich mir nie Gedanken darüber,
dass ich anders aussehe.
Ich wusste nur,
dass meine langen Haare weg waren.
Dann fragte ich die Pflege
nach einem Spiegel.
Sie gaben mir so einen Handspiegel.
Sie setzten mir den
einfach in die Hand.
Er bewegte sich dann so fest,
dass ich mich nicht wirklich sah -
bis sie es mir dann zeigten.
Dann ...
Ja, dann sah ich mein Spiegelbild.
Aber ich
konnte das fast nicht glauben.
Ich habe mich
wie nicht darin gesehen,
obwohl ich wusste,
dass ich in den Spiegel schaue.
Das war eigentlich interessant.
Das Interesse, mich zu sehen,
war von Anfang an da.
Das war aber auch
sehr schnell wieder weg.
Ich liess das Bild
nicht an mich heran.
Das hatte sich dann
wie erledigt für mich.
Guten Morgen, Herr Bosshard.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Guten Tag. Sehr gut.
- Ja?
Es geht mir immer gut,
wenn ich Sie sehe.
Das ist so.
Die Umstände
sind nicht immer schön ...
... aber das tut mir immer sehr gut.
- Das freut mich.
Die Intensivpfleger ...
... und Physiotherapeuten
und behandelnden Ärzte
wurde wie zu meiner Familie.
Sie konnten mich auf
eine sehr schöne Art und Weise ...
... bei Laune halten.
Als das Team und ich letztes Jahr
die Bilder des fünften Jahrestages
des Unfalls sahen,
als er
seinen ersten Triathlon machte ...
... standen einigen
die Tränen in den Augen.
Das Team war wirklich ergriffen
von dem, was möglich ist.
Wie jeder schwer Brandverletzte
musste Philipp Schmerzen aushalten,
die die Persönlichkeit verändern.
Und wie jeder schwer Brandverletzte
spielte er mit dem Gedanken,
sein Leben zu beenden,
um den Schmerzen zu entkommen.
Ich erinnere mich gut ...
Was mir blieb, ist v.a., wie es war,
als ich nach den Verbandswechseln
jeweils aufwachte.
Die machte man lange unter Narkose,
weil es nicht anders ging.
Aber das Zurückkommen
fühlte sich für mich an,
als würde man mich
in einen Rosenbusch werfen,
der sehr viele Dornen hat.
So fühlte sich das an.
Die Augen gingen auf und die
Realität brach über einen hinein.
Es kam alles zurück
und dann setzte der Schmerz ein.
Das war wirklich so, als würde ich
in den Busch reingedrückt werden.
Es stach und brannte
am ganzen Körper.
Es gab Situationen,
in denen er tief eintauchte.
Da ging es ihm gar nicht gut.
Da hatten wir auch das Gefühl,
dass er den Weg mit uns
so nicht weitergehen kann.
Da besprachen wir uns
mit seiner Familie
und gingen als Behandlungsteam
über die Bücher
und überlegten,
ob das das Richtige für ihn sei.
Wir definierten für uns,
wie weit wir noch gehen können ...
... wenn er wirklich nicht mehr mag.
Das geht wieder
in den ethischen Bereich rein:
die Zurechnungsfähigkeit
der Patienten.
Wie sollen wir verwerten, was
der Patient uns gegenüber äussert?
Er hat in anderen Situationen
erzählt, dass er nicht mehr konnte,
und sich auch als anderes, ver-
ändertes Wesen wahrgenommen hatte -
wegen der ausgeprägten Schmerzen.
Er hatte auch Phasen,
in denen er für seine Umwelt
nicht der Philipp Bosshard war,
der er vorher war oder heute ist.
Es ist ziemlich makaber,
und das schüttelt mich richtig.
Ich habe oft das Tram gehört
und brachte das
in Verbindung mit dem Zug.
Ich überlegte, ob ich das machen
würde, wenn ich die Chance hätte.
Natürlich geht das zum Glück nicht,
aber man macht sich die Gedanken.
Das war die dunkelste Phase
dieser ganzen Zeit
auf der Intensivstation.
Das Motivationsposter
schien zu wirken:
Die Phase mit Selbstmordgedanken
ist bei Philipp sehr kurz -
verglichen mit anderen Patienten.
Auch körperlich
geht es langsam aufwärts:
wieder ohne Hilfe trinken,
das erste Mal aufstehen -
kleine Fortschritte,
mit grossem Einsatz verdient.
Bei den ersten Schritten
aus dem Zimmer raus -
immer noch mit Begleitung
und Stützen usw. ...
... klatschte das ganze Intensivteam
und feuerte mich an.
Das war verdammt schön für mich.
Diese ersten zwei Schritte
waren ein grosser Meilenstein.
Nach einem Jahr
darf Philipp die Intensivstation
Richtung Rehaklinik verlassen.
Philipp findet Anschluss
in der Gruppe von Francesca Brenni,
Sportphysiotherapeutin mit einem
Händchen für Menschen mit Handicap.
Früher tätig in der Rehaklinik
Bellikon, heute selbstständig.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp.
Ich hatte null Erfahrung
mit Verbrennungspatienten -
zumindest in dem Stadium.
Ich habe in Lausanne
während eines Praktikums
in einem Verbrennungszentrum
Verbrennungspatienten gesehen,
aber in der Frühphase
auf der Intensivstation.
Die habt ihr mit Philipp ja besucht.
Das war für mich: "Woah."
Was er erlebt hat,
ist sehr schwierig.
Dann kam er auf mich zu
und machte es einfach für mich.
Das muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Er ist ein Sonnenschein.
Er kommt
und macht dein Leben einfacher.
Ich habe viel
mit ihm darüber gesprochen,
was er will und was nicht.
Ich merkte,
dass er etwas ziellos war.
Man hatte ihn
als Pflegefall abgestempelt.
"Du lebst. Sei froh, dass du lebst."
Das war Philipp am Anfang.
Ich habe ihm sozusagen einfach Ziele
zugeworfen und ausprobiert.
Ich sah sie immer
im Kraftraum der Rehaklinik.
Ich hörte
ihren sportlichen Drill jeweils.
Sie förderte
die anderen Patienten wirklich.
Das imponierte mir stark.
Ich wusste, dass ich das brauche.
Allez. Super.
Drill heisst auch:
raus
aus der Turnhalle der Rehaklinik,
rein in die Öffentlichkeit.
Sich unter Menschen trauen.
Als wir das ersten Mal
in Davos snowboarden gingen ...
... konnte er nicht schlafen.
Ich weiss das,
weil er mir das erzählte.
Bei ihm war das oft so,
wenn wir etwas Neues machten.
Er fand: "Kann ich nicht."
Ich habe ihn
dann einfach vorangetrieben.
Dann machte er es.
Matthias nahm ihn auch viel mit
und machte vieles mit ihm.
Ich glaube, das macht viel aus.
Mit Francesca und seinem Freund
Matthias fühlt sich Philipp sicher.
Er erlebt viele erste Male:
das erste Mal Langlaufen.
Das erste Mal auf dem Snowboard.
Die erste Passfahrt.
Der erste Halbmarathon.
Das ist krass.
Als wir z.B.
das erste Mal joggen gingen,
konnten wir 2 Min. am Stück rennen,
dann mussten wir Pause machen.
Und jetzt macht er
einen Halbmarathon in 2 Std.
Francesca Brenni
hat Philipps Leben mit dem Sport
einen Sinn und eine Struktur gegeben.
Job erledigt? Noch lange nicht.
Ich bin Sportphysio.
Ich habe mit ihm
eigentlich mein Ziel erreicht.
Als Freundin ...
... hoffe ich, dass er ...
... beruflich auch
etwas findet, das ihm Spass macht
und ihm weiter Ziele ...
Darum sage ich, dass es
für mich noch nicht fertig ist.
Er ist noch nicht fertig.
Ich glaube,
dass er noch andere Ziele braucht.
Aber er ist jung und kann sich
sicher noch weiterentwickeln.
Philipp ist jemand,
der nach vorne schaut.
Er hat alle Chancen,
seinen Weg zu gehen.
Meine Selbstständigkeit
weiterzuführen.
Diesen Wegweiser gab sie mir
bei unserer ersten Begegnung -
bis hin zum Loslassen.
Aber das begleitet mich
auch jetzt noch.
Sie ist und wird
eine lebenslange Begleiterin sein.
Ähm ... Ja.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Das Engadin - je länger je mehr
Philipps zweite Heimat.
Er ist vor der Sommerhitze in Bülach
geflohen.
Nur in der Kühle der Berge
kann er trainieren,
weil er nicht schwitzen kann.
Philipps vernarbte Haut
hat keine Schweissdrüsen mehr.
Training und Bewegung
sind für mich Lebensqualität.
Ich gehe jetzt im Training sehr
gerne an meine körperlichen Grenzen.
Auf der Intensivstation
musste ich jeweils
an meine Schmerzgrenze gehen.
Das hat sich in mir manifestiert.
Das lote ich jetzt im Training aus.
Das mache ich auch sehr gerne.
Bewegung ist Freiheit für mich.
Im Spital war ich immer gefesselt
und hatte keine Perspektiven.
Es ist ein Neustart.
Hier ist Philipp kein Unfallopfer,
er ist einfach nur Sportler.
Er führt
das Leben eines Profi-Triathleten.
Ich behaupte, das war einer meiner
besten Sommer, die ich hatte.
V.a. nach dem Unfall.
Ich machte in allen Belangen
die meisten Fortschritte.
Auch für mich selber.
Was heisst das?
Ich spreche von meinem Wohlbefinden
in dieser neuen Haut.
Ich konnte
in eine ganz andere Rolle schlüpfen
bzw. habe gelernt,
da reinzuschlüpfen.
Durch das Umfeld im Engadin.
Die Leute kommen mir entgegen,
so wie ich bin.
Das Äusserliche
tritt in den Hintergrund.
Ich bin Philipp der Mensch.
Man fixiert sich
nicht auf das Spezielle.
Das tut mir sehr gut.
Einfach nur Athlet und ausserdem
Teil einer Trainingsgruppe.
Gleichgesinnte,
die Geborgenheit stiften.
Philipps Trainerin Semira Bontognali
erlebt ihren Schützling
als beflügelt.
Ich muss ihn eher mal bremsen.
Ich muss ihm nie sagen "Du
musst das machen" oder "Geh jetzt".
Es ist wirklich so ...
Philipp ist sehr motiviert
und sehr diszipliniert.
Er lernt eigentlich sehr schnell,
hinterfragt aber auch viel.
Bis er findet, dass es passt.
Er steht sich selber
ein bisschen im Weg,
weil er alles hinterfragt.
Semira Bontognali
ist die rechte Hand Brett Suttons,
der auch zahlreiche
Weltklasseathleten betreut.
Der Australier
interessiert sich keinen Deut
für die Vergangenheit
seiner Sportler, nur für ihre Ziele.
Wenn Menschen ein Handicap
oder ein Problem haben wie Philipp,
versuche ich das zu ignorieren,
damit sie sehen, dass ich sie
gleich behandle wie alle anderen.
Wenn ich mich mit ihrer Geschichte
befasse, werde ich emotional.
Das wissen wenige,
aber ich bin ein emotionaler Typ.
Philipp wird genau gleich
und manchmal genauso streng
angepackt wie der Rest.
Ich denke, er geniesst das,
weil viele Leute ihm
nicht die Wahrheit sagen.
Wir sind ehrlich miteinander.
Wenn er keinen guten Job macht,
stauchen wir ihn zusammen,
wie alle anderen auch.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Die Natur, die man hier um sich hat,
ist unglaublich.
Das gibt mir sehr viel Energie und
auch Motivation für das Training.
Das ist ein Kontrast zu dem,
was ich im Spital erleben musste.
Das ist wirklich pure Freiheit.
Das geht unter die Haut.
Zurück in Locarno.
Philipps Nervosität ist verflogen.
Seine Freunde machen
einen Triumphlauf aus dem Rennen.
Go, Philipp!
Und dank Kühlweste und Kühlstirnband
trotzt Philipp der Hitze.
Nach 2 Std. und 51 Min.
darf er sich Finisher nennen.
Doch die Zeit spielt keine Rolle.
* Jubel *
Bravo, Philipp.
Das ist ...
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Das war einfach ein grosses Ziel.
Sport tut mir so gut.
Und dass mich
so viele Leute unterstützen.
Das ist überhaupt
nicht selbstverständlich.
Ja, es ist einfach wunderschön.
Menschen haben Ziele.
Philipp hat seines erreicht.
Er hat dafür
mit aller Kraft gekämpft.
Aber er weiss:
Alleine hätte er es nicht geschafft.
Starke Leistung.
- Gleichfalls, danke.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021